so we're my name is weboth and my friend
Jarek he in Polish it said Yosef but
then it in short it's called Eric
anyways we'll be talking about machine
learning to moderate ads in real-world
scenarios and not like good doing a POC
in competitions so this is going to be a
real one so first I'll I'll tell you
what around the agenda and what the
problem statement is how do we what is
the exact problem and how do we solve it
and also a bit about OLX because not
many people would know what OLX is all
about so yeah the first thing is a the
actual problem so let's so it will go
like the problem the model creation part
and going live with the product so what
is oil X OLX is a buying and selling
platform it's like a classifieds
platform where you can sell your
products or you can sell your mobile
phones your cars any product that you
have and there are many people trying to
buy it out so we operate in around 50
countries so it's not like one simple
country where you want solve a problem
we have to solve a problem for many
countries at the same time we have
around 60 plus monthly listings and
around 18 months 18 18 plus million
unique monthly sellers it's only the
seller spot there's a lot more when it
comes to the buyer spot as well so the
problem there what I'm trying to sell
here is we are not dealing with a very
small data set we are dealing with a
very big data set so what do we actually
do and what do the what do the
moderators to OLX employs a lot of
moderators because we all the data that
we have on the on the side is uses user
generated so it's not like you rated
content so everything that comes on the
platform needs to be moderated so what
kind of problems do we have what kind of
problems are the moderator is actually
trying to solve so there are many people
who are trying to cheat the system there
are many people who are trying to
violate the terms of services of the
platform and there other people who do
not were not educated enough or
we really do not know how they need to
publish their ad so the avoidance of
payment a common example is you want to
sell your BMW and then you have a car
you want to sell it out but in certain
countries you need to pay to put pasta
mat on the platform so once you have
sold a car people change their at now
they have a second small car say I
afford a small Ford and then they change
the whole ad from being able to afford
and then this is how they avoid the
payment the second biggest problem is
they flood our websites with with
duplicate ads so because as soon as we
post an ad there are so many other
people trying to post that your ad goes
down the page views as the page numbers
and you lose your visibility so people
try to post their ads multiple times and
this is this remove this reduces the
quality of content that we have on a
platform and it's not good for the
buyers as well they also create a try to
create multiple accounts because
sometimes in certain countries you get
three ads per per customer per user
account so they you create multiple
accounts so that you can post multiple
things similar now coming to terms of
services we have every every site has
its own terms of services you can post a
description phone numbers on the images
but we have to get rid of all these kind
of images and one common thing is like
people try to sell of guns and other
things on the platform itself by just
they learn how to evade keyword keyword
rule-based system so like in India they
were trying to sell money during the
demon utilization phase where people
were trying to sell banknotes on the
platform and this was totally forbidden
missed categorization is basically
people do not know which category their
production belong to so we help our
customers to categorize them better I
think yeah this this would be enough
there are other problems that we're
trying to solve but then this limited
time comes limited features so I'll pass
the mic to Arya I have
okay so Yannick we can continue with the
offline model creation okay so I'm
Joseph Sims a controlled yarek and I'll
tell you a few words about offline model
creation so this part when you start
your project with the very beginning is
always the question how to convert your
ad into a set of features so what would
you like to extract from the ad what
additional information for example about
the user that posted the dot you could
concatenate with the information that
you have about the ad itself and so on
and so on
so basically the most important part for
us is the title and description and in
any moderation the content of of the
thing but is moderated is the most
important so any other things would be
additional and I will not go into exact
details because some of those things are
just specific to the way how our whole
moderation tool works so basically when
you have this number of features and
very often you know the classic of
classics tf-idf even more basic version
is just a count of words which is a
count vectorizer
if you do it on a couple of million of
ads you can imagine how large the number
of features that you have to process
would be so basically you can do for
example feature selection for some of
the classifiers that might require it
some of them do not then we actually
don't really need that much to do the
feature selection only in order to avoid
leakage but I will tell more about later
so basically once you have your features
things like category are straightforward
you just want out and coat them with
expects to riser in scikit-learn for
example or with pandas get dummies but
then the already in the previous talk
one of our colleagues mentioned there is
a hashing trick so when you have this
large number of features
and they are very sparse you don't need
to have for each of the feature separate
column you can just reduce it by
assigning each of such features to one
of the bucket an example with categories
I just would like to place them in two
buckets here I assign the buckets it's
not of course a random assignment but
this assignment is from the hashing
function and the hashing function simply
gives you a large number then you define
the number of buckets that you want to
have and I will modular or some other
operations I'm not sure how exactly it
is implemented in scikit-learn
inside you simply have distributed your
words between the number of buckets that
you chosen so we use around 200,000
buckets for description and 50,000
buckets for for title and that works
with a very similar quality to the count
vectorizer itself so it is actually in
our case - to speed up the computations
the things that you need to be aware of
when you develop the model even in
offline part is the beta leakage so
sometimes there is this Epiphany that
you have Wow my model is so great as I
improved
I didn't even assume that it would be so
good and it probably isn't probably you
just have a data leakage because
probably you have the feature that
wouldn't be available at the prediction
time for example when we use the feature
that we really had to be careful with is
the number of ads that user has and the
number of accepted ads that user has
because if you combine the two and you
save it after the moderation or the
human labeling took place you have your
leakage because actually this number
reflects already the decision so you
your leakage can come from many sources
because for example this count can be
equated to a database that is then sent
to you to your service by our team
so the leakage doesn't need to come from
yourself for example you you need to be
aware of it and the leakage that doesn't
come from your processing is not
possible to detect easily withhold
outset because if you do the whole
pre-processing yourself just have a
holdout set do not touch the labels
there and you're good to go you just
evaluate that the performance is is
similar on on holdout and on validation
but if your leakage comes from outside
you will have it already in in your test
set in your holdout and in such case you
need to monitor if you have a live
system you need to monitor the live
performance and ensure but it is the
same as as you expect so just a few
words about the algorithm we wanted
something that is state-of-the-art for
structured problems that when it under
fits you can do something like extend
the learning time by the number of
rounds for example and you overcome the
underfitting when it's over feeds you
can come up with various regularization
to ensure that it doesn't anymore and it
has efficient implementation all things
added gives a cube roof so I will not go
into details about XG boost but I just
have this shameless plug about the
presentation that I made about it and I
encourage you to take take a look and I
will focus more on evaluation of the
model because this is one of the most
important part first choose your measure
accuracy isn't always the best because
if you have some rare event and you say
that for example you have one percent of
people that are sick and you want to
detect it and you say what everyone is
healthy you already have 99% accuracy
but it's totally useless
so also one thing which was seen before
is receiver operator area under curve of
receiver operator curve so basically and
I think it is not the common knowledge
about how to interpret the aria
so for for binary classification and
especially in medical sciences settings
area under ROC is like the gold standard
to evaluate the test but what it
actually means this area under curve it
means that here you have the negative
samples here we have the positive
samples for each of the sample you
assign the score and now randomly you
take one negative and one positive and
the probability that the positive sample
has a higher score with a negative
sample is equal to area under curve and
this interpretation has a certain
consequence this consequence is that it
doesn't really matter what is the
proportion of your negative to positive
examples because this probability as
long as the distribution stays the same
also stays the same so for example in
our case when our models perform better
and better of course and we have fewer
and fewer human labeled examples of the
ads that were positive so the ratio is a
revert velvet that were ok with you're
good at let's call it like that so this
ratio changes over time and then
suddenly you see that on other metrics
like for example precision your solution
goes down the deteriorates the question
is why and the answer what we found out
is because the actually the the area
under curve ROC is the same just the
proportion of the data changed so you
need to think of one one KPI
but it's relevant for your business for
example this area under curve is nice
but doesn't really try to talk to
business people about it right I dare
you you need to find out something that
relates to business and to be to
business requirements so when you have
this natural border of zero five score
legend you have
call from zero to one zero five
everything above but you classify as
positive and the number the diffraction
of things that are positive there is
called precision so how precisely you
predicted something but you can modify
this threshold sometimes you can simply
don't give a decision and when you
increase this threshold precision goes
up it has certain limits but it goes
basically it goes up this if it's not
totally random classifier on the other
hand if you lower your threshold you
increase the recall and recall is like
you have this number of of things that
you want to to catch and it's the
fraction of the ones that you actually
caught like for example there are fishes
in the sea and how many of them instead
of other things like boots and so on you
cut and as you see there is this
trade-off you move this either up or
down to have a curve that you can create
so this is an ROC and this is precision
recall curve with this threshold Inc and
when you set the threshold after every
possible value of thresholds that there
are and you have a curve like that and
then with your business requires from
you that please find at least half of
all bad ads that are very least and try
to be precise because we don't want to
waste our moderators work you just
freeze the Ricoh and try to maximize the
precision you don't really care about
the area under the curve but simply
about precision at the certain points on
the other hand is a requirement that we
actually have human moderators have
certain precision and we don't want the
machine to be worse because it's bad PR
so basically you try to maximize Rico
and having the same precision as humans
so to conclude just think of your what
your business requirements are and try
to find the KPI that could be also a
machine learning measure that could work
both for business and for you and that
you could easily justify and
actually optimize the things that when
business takes a look at I give the flow
back to vodka thank you very much
all right so now you have done the POC
part so you have done a bit of modeling
you have done some kind of evaluation
now you want to put this in production
so the first thing what you need to do
is you need to see how big your data is
how how it is your data really really
big so we deal a lot with the we started
with dealing with a lot of contracts
Rises tf-idf vector writers and came
with hashing which writers so we create
a lot of feature space but then they did
number of laser points at some point
finally saw that the the validation
actually should be decrease so if you
keep the number of data points and if
you can limit the feature space then
your data is not really big outside but
this is a very controversial topic we
can talk later about this one so what
this is one thing that we do so once we
create a lot of features when so we have
all the future generation steps pipeline
done what we do is we export all these
features using the normal psychic dump
this dump a dim light format this is
very good because I do not know the
speed speed versus the hdf5 is which are
much better plus you can stop at certain
point of time and then you can continue
later on if you really want to so this
is really memory efficient you can
separate your future generation pipeline
with the actual model training pipeline
this is really good the one thing one
drawback of SVM light is you do not know
the number of features you do not
exactly know this the columns the
feature columns that you have so you
need to extract your feature columns
differently so what did we learn what we
learned that do not use distributed
learning if you don't mean to if you can
if you can have your job done in one
machines or two machines at the max it's
good enough do not really over optimize
your
choose your tech a dependent add the
same thing to the tech dependent on the
data size if you cannot solve the
problem on your local machine there's
always a clouds it can be Amazon Google
importnat you can choose whatever and
always ask yourself a question what is
the most difficult problem that you
won't escape I would say it's people
because getting a lot of talented people
is a problem and if you really choose
off-the-chart different algorithms or
different solutions you will not get
enough developers or data scientists to
team up with you next thing is the model
generation pipeline what I would say
here is automate because if you do not
automate you'll not be your problem your
solutions will not not be deterministic
what do automated is a really big
problem for us because we tend to have
similar kind of models for all the
different countries so we do not want to
do the same thing again and again the
prediction different data sets we have a
similar kind of pipeline we just we have
we use Luigi to automate the pipeline
and we make move deterministic this way
so it's not about only using Luigi you
can use anything you can use air flow
there's easy and there's many more job
management libraries out there what you
need to choose whichever you're
comfortable with we are comfortable with
Luigi because it is very simple and if
you know Python you can easily make a
dependent jobs airflow is also good if
you air flow you ice is really good but
if you're really doing like day to day
jobs
cron jobs air flow is really good but
then if you are doing like once you know
we kind of jobs
Louise is good enough so this is a
normal Luigi dashboard where you see
your pending tasks your jobs in progress
your failed has and all that sorts it's
very simple UI you can't do much this is
our data model generation pipeline so we
in an in children we create we extract
the features we create the SPM files we
export this SCM files
then we train anak XE boost morale and
then then model validation so this is a
very this is very specific to Luigi
because how does Luigi know if the job
is done it if you create an output file
this is how Luigi knows that you're out
that your job is finished
and if your job breaks in the middle and
you still have an output file
Luigi if you run Luigi again it'll think
okay your job is already done why should
I do it again so always try to create
the output file in the end creating
dynamic dependencies English is really
easy you can use eel you can use
requires which I want to choose this the
last thing is the workers thing we I
didn't know when I started using Luigi
about the workers but then if you have
number of many course on your machine
you can scale up your Luigi TAS jobs
using workers now comes development and
production environments so normally what
I've when I talk to many people they
designed this they create their models
they ship their models and then they say
ok my job is done well this is not the
case for every every team we we create
the models we train the models to
evaluate publish them and monitor them
so how do we do this the easiest way is
to container eyes and this is how you
manage your dependencies so you create
docker containers you orchestrate them
using Cuba natives or whatever solution
you want to choose and then you deploy
them this is our normal model serving
architecture it is a very typical
architecture if you google for how to
serve your Python models we have flasks
on top of our models and of course our
learning model is psych 8xg boot space
we do all the monitoring using Griffin
and Uralic can we save everything that
is coming to us in [ __ ] Laster well
people say why flask because flask
normally is processed blocking kind of
operations people tend to use other
frameworks in Python like tornado but
you can easily use flask as well
you can use G event you can use Q's we
use both and then it's basically very
fast it's asynchronous it's very fast
and then you can you can scale up very
easily this is one slide this is our
image model serving architecture we do a
lot of with images as well as I told
before we create we create hashes so
this is a fast pipeline because as soon
as the images are coming and we need to
moderate all of these images and if so
for each ad we get like four or five
images so it's really exponential
problem to solve the image drop so the
images - we do a lot of hash generation
this is for image similar a similar
image search this is for duplicate
detection plus you can also use for
image search itself then they are
country specific image moderation like
in India they don't allow human pictures
humans with faces in the pictures we
have to develop you have to remove these
pictures in folium they do not allow
stock images so you have to remove them
these kind of image moderation and then
there's general moderation NSFW eh which
we have to remove then comes category
and tag prediction we as I told before
if we need to categorize all the ads of
course people choose their category but
then using images we can suggest them ok
this piece of cup should go into a use
product I don't know which cut it so we
store all the models on s3 as soon as we
deploy we download the monster mystery
and then this is how we make the
prediction module that's it so yep so
you have deployed your production a your
model into production here everything is
going fine but your job is still not
done you need to evaluate how your model
is behaving in real-life scenarios
because the test data said that it shows
before might change as the problem is on
life so here is a ISM so what do we do
here what we do is in LX we sample all
the predictions that come to us and send
it to moderators and madres moderators
do not know that this is being
predicted or not as in this came from
machine learning or is it a life like
that so this is how we know that our
models are behaving good or not we
calculate their rates based on sampling
second thing is ye if you have a graph
like this you will know that you can
create alerts when your error rates are
going higher and also once we have a lot
of models so it's like one or two models
you can handle itself but then once you
have three hundred-plus models and you
have two people working on this 300-plus
model system you need to create reports
we create daily reports to see how we
are doing in day because proms will
change every day there will be a emails
and it'll be a spam of snap in spam in
one country and there will be different
kinds of problems coming up in different
countries so you need to need to be
aware and proactive once I have deployed
these models so the lessons that we have
learnt using molten production is always
batch this goes for images this goes for
normal prediction so using batching
using kanessa sees in Kafka you can
easily batch earlier all your prediction
messages and you can easily do two
predictions on that and this will this
will definitely reduce your CPUs CPU
utilization on the machines always model
arise your code so that is easy to read
to always make a clean code so that you
can have many people in your team
contributing to it plus always authorize
and orchestrate because this helps you
and finally once you have so many models
learning online definitely use a
monitoring service because if you do not
you will never know if your model is
behaving badly
and finally simple and easy tech do not
take too much of headache of using spark
Hadoop clusters use simple easy tech
which you can manage and that's about it
so if you have any more questions you
can come back to us
if you have any questions please to ask
so thanks for the talk out of curiosity
you mentioned data leakage you mentioned
that for instance if you if you're
taking data that your ads that have
already been moderated then of course
it's leaking but you also mentioned
external leakage what did you mean by
that and so for example and not always
you are responsible for the data
preparation and the leakage doesn't have
to happen from your processing it can
happen from processing for example and
before you even acquires the data the
read what I meant but it can happen
externally outside of your supervision
so the fact that you know that you
didn't introduce the leakage doesn't
mean that there is none and so we didn't
have this but for example when when we
receive the learning art it's also as a
service so and we have a moderation tool
and from the moderation tool we receive
a JSON but if mmm has all the features
that we need for the art for example
including the count of number of arts
that user have and number of us that
user had rejected and number of ads
which is we had accepted if someone for
example would do the count on on those
numbers after do the count after the
moderation decision would be done for
example user has one ad and this ad is
rejected instead of having both zeros
because it's a new user you would have a
leakage because the only others user
have is rejected and that's how for
example with external leakage good could
come into into your data thank you hello
thanks for the interesting talk and you
made a lot of tech decisions like dr.
kubernetes Luigi and whatever is there
some technology that you regret or I
mean yes yes definitely so when we
started off with this project we thought
yeah we should definitely because the
data is really big we should choose Big
Data technologies right so we started
with spark ml we had Casca we had
zookeeper and all that sorts sooner we
realized a spark every used for a spark
spark ml lip for pre-processing and
sooner we realized that we're hitting a
bottleneck with using pipe using Python
and spark
so yes it's like it's pre-processing is
good enough hashing with riser is good
enough this goof it's like it then came
Casca cascada problem was Python
or maybe move to that like can we get
data like maybe this one maybe that
speakers oh just speaker okay yeah it's
good enough okay yeah okay everything so
yeah the Kappa the
the problem with casco is a partition a
partitioning balance so what Kafka does
is if you have many partitions it will
try to balance the number of messages in
each of these partitions and we're
hitting a problem where it was not able
to partition very fast as an it was
doing a lot of balancing of the
partitions and the nice area too much of
work just go with normal rabbit NP cues
the timing I like to ask more about the
implementation part I mean do you
provide your moderation team with the
width of the ads attaching with the
score or do you remove those ads before
going through the moderation team okay
so we in OLX do not just have machine
learning as the basis of moderation we
have rule-based engines so we we key tag
along with the rule-based engine soup
there are certainly definite that are
caught by rule-based engines and they're
thrown away from the from the whole
process when there are ads that come too
to the moderation queues this can come
from us from our decisions that this
needs to be moderated in the in these
kind of cases we do not give a score we
with a suggestion so that we say we know
that in behind the scenes we are come we
are confident that this this ad should
be read rejected because it has
something like guns and the anything so
we suggest the rejection reasons to the
to the moderators we also suggest like
if the price is wrong with the with the
particular product we also suggest if
the categories is wrong so so we we also
do a lot of suggestion so that we can
help a moderators make the decisions
faster I thanks for the talk and I would
like to know if what kind of interface
or how the communication process is
between the data engineering team and
the data science team and
and so this is a very so in in OLX we of
course we believe with a lot of data and
we have huge data engineering streams
and we have our own moderation teams for
us it's not that big of a problem
because our basis everything that we
have made is ourselves everything that
comes to us is comes through us as a
REST API and we validate all the data
that is coming to us so we do not have a
lot of noisy data but more or less
structured data that comes to us there
is a lot of tracking data that other
people deal with and there it's a
different engineering team a different
business unit and all X that does that
for us it's not it's not that big of a
problem of data engineering
[Music]
[Applause]